after Final Fantasy 15 s big event this
week the news just keeps on pouring in
director had you made tabata recently
spoke to dengeki online about the game's
new platinum demo and more I'm Lucy and
welcome to your lads on tour gamespot
news update according to a translation
from jewel shockers speaking about the
free platinum demos resolution Tabata
San said that the team used a dynamic
resolution with 1080p being the limit as
for frame rate which some have remarked
could be better Tabata son made it clear
that the demos goal was not to be a
technical showcase but rather to give
the players a taste of the world before
launch the technical specifications for
the platinum demo are the same for
playstation 4 and xbox one he said
though he's not sure if the same will be
true for the final release he also
pledged that Square Enix will spend time
between now and launch optimizing the
game so it can look and perform as good
as possible however there are no plans
to update the platinum demo as square
enix did with episode 2 sky but those
weren't the only tidbits from the
interview Final Fantasy 15 will be
playable at e3 and possibly at other
events before its launch on sep tember
30th Tabata son believes there may be
free and paid DLC for Final Fantasy down
the road but there's no word yet on what
form it will take he also reiterated
that a pc version of 15 could be
released after the console launch but
nothing's been decided yet so what did
you make of the platinum demo are you as
in love with carbuncle as I am let me
know in the comments below or come find
me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James games
for more on Final Fantasy 15 keep a
gamespot